hey dr. Burke here you know a lot of
times patients will ask me what when I
do a ketosis diet which is a higher
protein high fat diet I get fatigued oh
you have lethargy what is that and how
do i combat that in this video I'm going
to show you exactly how to get rid of
fatigue or a lethargy when you do the
ketosis diet but real briefly ketosis is
the process where you're actually
switching the fuel source to more fat
burning because typically our bodies
will run always on sugar as a priority
if given the chance and you have about
72 hours of sugar to run on and then it
switches over to fat if you go into
ketosis diet but to do that the purpose
of fat is to protect you against the
starvation of sugar so you want to
starve the body of sugar to be able to
convert over into the fat-burning mode
the great majority of people do not burn
fat because they have a little too much
sugar in the diet you have to literally
starve the body of sugar to be able to
really get into this mechanism right
here and the body has to make all these
different new machinery or enzymes to be
able to break down this fuel and and it
takes a period of time to do that it
might take three days to two weeks to
build this up and so and it takes like
you have enough sugar to last you a
while so your body will deplete this and
then it starts to convert over right
here now the one nutrient that your body
needs in this mechanism and if it
doesn't have this one nutrient you are
going to have fatigue and lethargy is
vitamin b5 pantothenic acid so vitamin
b5 is kind of like a Co Co vitamin a
helper vitamin it allows the metabolism
of fat and the cool thing is about about
b5 is it also really supports the
adrenal gland so if you have adrenal
fatigue it really will help the
metabolism to build up more energy so I
just wanted to make a point of this so
if you're noticing fatigue
you're getting tired that type of thing
go to help the store get some vitamin b5
and that those symptoms will go right
away you'll feel better you'll be able
to metabolize better and you can really
make this transition very effectively
hope that helped and I will see you in
the next video